mike shield and the cardinals looking
for a franchise tying 14th consecutive
win tonight zach davies and he has not
won a game since july 23rd goldschmidt
two out of four a home run three rbis
and a strikeout in game one and the
one-two pitch
lined for a base head into center field
paul goldschmidt paul goldschmidt is now
nine for his last 14. o'neal one for
four with a two run homer that was in
game one the one
it's sharply in a basin into left so
back-to-back singles runners at first
and second base is loaded here in this
first inning and yadier molina comes up
he did not appear in game one the 2-1
for molina he swings and he hits it deep
left center field and on the run the
ball goes off of ortega's glove and all
the way to the wall
two-run score
stopping at third nolan oronato yadier
molina drives in two with a double the
cardinals are on top in the nightcap
that was quite a flying try for rafael
ortega but he could not hold on the ball
came off his glove while he was falling
to the grass and here's harrison vader
spader with runners at second and third
banner up the middle base hit
one run in to hold molina it's a
three-nothing st louis lead here in the
top of the first arena scores
i love vader's approach with this at bat
you could tell he's not trying to do too
much he's looking to send the ball up
the middle send it to that part of the
field not trying to pull a roll over in
a double play situation right there
fantastic 15 pitch bullpen session
tuesday in milwaukee did not make a
rehab start or assignment welcome back
jack flaherty
swaying and a miss and a strikeout for
flaherty welcome back jack and it brings
up frank schwendel
that one back up the middle in a base
hit and frank schwendell
add another
he's now hit in 13 in a row patrick
nothing for three with three strikeouts
in the opener here comes the 3-2 pitch
swinging a drive center field and deep
back goes vader it's got a
chance gone
long gone
get out the tape measure for patrick
wisdom it's now 3-2 saint lou the wind
is blowing out hard to straight away
center if you get it elevated wisdom
pounds this ball to the middle of the
diamond and i think it leaves the
ballpark just to the right of the
bleachers in left field a long home run
the 27 year old dakota hudson welcome
back to you and he underwent tommy
john's surgery it was just about a year
ago
last september 28th so yadi sets up
outside it's the slider backed up a bit
but he gets the strikeout and hudson his
first strikeout of 20-21 in the big
leagues with men now at first and third
and the batter is tyler o'neil he's got
the green light right here oh yeah a 3-0
pitch to tyler o'neil oh neil smokes it
oh and he knew it it's gone
his second home run of the day
skipping out of the box he knew that
baby was out of here
the man
is on fire the canadian crusher he's so
fired up listen 30 was a big number 31
lock it in three more rbis to the trees
he's feeling it as you should large newt
bar
will lead off this third inning newt
barr with a fly ball
deep right center and gone
large
nude bar
must be a lot of cardinal fans and
wrigley here in the nudes they can't go
wrong get out of here ball good for newt
you could see the excitement he needed
that one you can see that all over his
face round and second coming around
third and that brings in de young who
flied out his first time
and a young
headset out to deep right back to back
newt barr
de young and we're having a little
friday night fun at wrigley there we go
there's the smile i was waiting for
worked himself back into a 3-2 count got
a fastball out over and pounded it man
it's good to see the cardinals lighting
up the ball like this frank schwendell
will lead off the cub third against
dakota hudson
san diego six and a half a drive in the
left center another extra base knock for
schwendell
big frank cruising into second with a
standing double he just hung out a
laser-like line drive
it short hopped the wall out in left
center and he's two for two one away and
a man at third and the batter is ian
happ the o2 now to hap
ground ball it'll get a run in it goes
to the left side aronado gloves it
running throw to first in time scoring
on the play schwendell it's now an 8-3
ball game harrison an rbi single in the
first inning lined up to short in the
second
he swings and lands one down the left
field line that's a fair ball going to
the corner harrison bader races into
second base with a double his second
double in the doubleheader and that's
his fourth hit overall today he's two
out of three in the nightcap it's been a
double machine in the month of september
lars newt barr broke an o for 23 hitting
a home run into the bleachers in right
center field newt barr base headed to
right bader will score and this will
make it a 9-3
st louis lead new bar comes through
again that ball's up and in at 94. at
94. the cardinals are swinging it so
duffy gets a pinch hit rafael ortega is
at the plate
[Applause]
here's ortega driving window right
center field deep on the run newt barr
can't get it
it's played on a bounce out there by
bader it's going to be a sliding double
for rafael ortega and the cubs have men
at second and third with nobody out
schwendell hit by a pitch that'll load
the bags ian happ is up the pitch to hap
fly ball toward right field newt barr is
there to make the catch it's deep enough
to drive in a run here comes duffy to
score hard hit ball by half but right to
the right fielder it's now a nine to
four cardinal lead as duffy scored david
bode is going to bat for the left-handed
hitting nick martini the 0-1 pitch
and bodhi chops it left side aronado is
there
penises cabrera comes in with the bases
loaded and nobody out and only one run
scores no vader likes to hit against
those lefties he's got two hits tonight
and boehner hits it out to deep left
center another one
he loves hitting against the lefties
harrison bader home run number 13.
and vader
is now just a triple away from the cycle
10-4
st louis lars newt barr hit his fourth
home run of the year earlier in the ball
game
oh is this fun who are these guys are
you kidding me two outs for paul
goldsmith why not cap off the day paul
and goldie
laces one to right that ball is down and
all the way into the corner de young
will be waved in he will score
goldschmidt on his way to second base
and goldie now three shy of 100 driven
in this year two down one to go with a
runner at second and patrick wisdom
coming to bed
popped up
and this will do it
aronado there
this is a september to remember the 2021
cardinals have tied the all-time record
held by the 1935
team 14 consecutive wins a doubleheader
sweep at wrigley
you